all right so now we're going to wrap up
the entire
trump portion of the show this is a
really important update
on a story from uh last week last week
you might remember that the new york
times's maggie haberman
tweeted an absolutely outrageous story
which was that donald trump has been
telling people around him that he
believes he's going to be reinstated to
the white house
uh as soon as august of this year now as
a reminder
haberman tweeted quote trump has been
telling a number of people he's in
contact with that he expects
he will be reinstated by august no that
isn't how it works but simply sharing
the information
going on to say that it isn't happening
in a vacuum
it is happening as he faced the
possibility of an indictment
from the manhattan district attorney and
then lastly adding that quote he is not
putting out statements about the audits
in states
just for the sake of it he's been laser
focused on them
according to several people who've
spoken with him as well as
washington post reporting a few weeks
ago now when this story broke last week
a whole bunch of people started
immediately calling it fake news
and trump's blog right before it shut
down
uh also had a post where donald trump
was denying it but
since then the story has been
corroborated
and the truth as it often is with trump
is even crazier than the reality the
right
wing national review not a left-wing
bomb-throwing
uh publication not a publication that
trump has been calling fake news
the right-wing national review published
a story called
maggie haberman is right which actually
tells an even crazier story reporting
that it's not only trump
who thinks he's going to be reinstated
it's trump
and two republican senators as well
charles cook writes in the piece quote
instead they should have listened
because haberman's reporting was correct
i can attest from speaking to an array
of different sources
that donald trump does indeed believe
quite genuinely that he
along with former senators david perdue
and martha mcsally
will be reinstated to office this summer
after audits of the 2020 elections in
arizona
georgia and a handful of other states
have been completed i can attest too
that trump is trying hard to recruit
journalist politicians and other
influential figures
to promulgate this belief not as a
fundraising tool
or an infantile bit of trolling or a
trial balloon
but as a fact this
is nuts my friends and the article goes
on to say
and remember this is the conservative
national review saying this the article
goes on to say
the scale of trump's delusion is quite
startling
this is not merely an eccentric
interpretation of the facts
or an interesting foible nor is it an
irrelevant example of anguished
post-presidency chatter
it is a rejection of reality a rejection
of law
and ultimately a rejection of the entire
system of american government there is
no reinstatement clause
within the united states constitution
hell there is nothing even approximating
a reinstatement clause
within the united states constitution
the
election has been certified joe biden is
the president and until 2024 that is all
there is to it
doesn't matter what one's view of trump
is doesn't matter whether one voted for
or against trump
it doesn't matter whether one's view one
views trump's role within the republican
party favorably or unfavorably
we're talking here about cold hard
neutral facts
that obtain irrespective of one's
preferences
it is not too much to ask that the
former head of the executive branch
should understand them this is why i
said earlier in the show
a new litmus test a sort of a gut
check sanity check question to right
wingers
should be going forward what is the
soonest
you believe donald trump could again be
president trump says he's going to be
restarting rallies as soon as this month
send reporters to the rallies and say to
them sir
ma'am what is the soonest you believe
donald trump could be president and if
it's
any earlier than january of 2025
it's someone either living in a fantasy
world or someone very very ignorant so
not only was maggie haberman correct in
her reporting
not only has that been corroborated it
is not trump alone
but also david perdue and martha mcsally
who believe
i guess that they're going to be
reinstated to their senate seats
somehow sometime during this summer
these are really dangerous times
especially because and we'll talk about
this tomorrow
when this stuff inevitably doesn't
happen
will the trump acolytes again be moved
to real world violence and destruction
of property
and breaking and entering and
trespassing and violence that we saw on
january
6th that's the really scary part and
we'll probably talk more about that
tomorrow